King Charles III is the UK's new head of
state and head of the Royal Family
he's basically the CEO of the British
Monarchy and he has said that one of his
priorities is to bring down running
costs
last year the monkey cost the government
roughly 102 million pounds the
equivalent to 117 million dollars
according to the palace's annual
financial report
so here's what we know about where that
money comes from and how it's spent
I take this opportunity to continue the
tradition of surrendering the hereditary
revenues including the crown estate to
my government for the benefit of all the
cost of carrying out official duties
comes from something called The
Sovereign Grant here's how that works
in the 1700s the monarchy handed over
revenues from slaves of land known as
the crown estate to the government
these days the crown estate makes money
on a range of assets from retail
property to golf courses and even
offshore wind farms
and every year the government pays a
percentage of the profit's mainlanders
assets back to the monarchy
last year it totaled 99.6 million
dollars in addition to their vast
private wealth and income from
Investments which are not included here
the monarchy also received 11.4 million
dollars from Royal Palace Admissions and
rental properties this slice of income
was used to supplement the ground the
last year the monarchy also tapped a
reserve of grant money from past years
to meet its spending needs so where did
that money go the bulk of this spending
goes on the Monarch's operating costs
official travel and Property Maintenance
in total more than three million dollars
was spent last year on helicopter trips
and Journeys on the Royal train and 10
times more than that was used to employ
about a thousand people from footman to
florists who make up the Royal household
headquartered at Buckingham Palace the
palace itself has high running costs and
money spent on renovating it Rose 41
from the previous year
a 10-year project to refurbish
Buckingham palace's forecast to cost
around 426 million dollars according to
the last financial report
and there are costs we don't know some
Royal Watchers say the bill is higher
than stated because of the costs of
police protection for the family and the
cost of the Queen's funeral couldn't
immediately be determined
now this money is spent is particularly
pertinent at a time when people are
voicing concerns about soaring energy
bills and inflation in the UK is at its
highest in 40 years
I imagine this government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families 117 million dollars of taxpayer
money works out at about 1.73 or one
pound fifty per UK citizen King Charles
seemingly wants it to be even less than
that
demonstrating that the monarchy is good
value for money is more difficult in
tougher Economic Times and Charles's
plans are part of a careful Balancing
Act definitely performed by his mother
for 70 years
now it's his turn to walk that tightrope
[Music]